Ready for some Game of Thrones season seven
spoilers? No? Too bad! Bend the knee and keep
watching, because Game of Thrones' Season
7 premiere was memorable for many things,
like Arya Stark's vengeful assault on the
Frey family, Daenerys Targaryen finally reaching
Dragonstone, Euron Greyjoy declaring himself
for Queen Cersei, and Sansa giving Jon Snow
some serious sass. But despite all that, season
7 already sucks. You know why? Because Joffrey
is not in it. I miss you Joffrey, so much.
But that was all a bit overshadowed by the
cameo of Ed Sheeran, whose musical moment
on the show was unintentionally hilarious.
"It's a pretty song. I've never heard it before."
"It's a new one."
Sheeran's stint as a Lannister soldier might've
earned a roaring social media response, but
it was just one in a series of celebrity cameos
that have come and go on the show. Here are
some other famous faces who've popped up in
the Realm over the years.
Gary Lightbody
Sheeran was hardly the first musician to appear
on Game of Thrones. In Season 3, Snow Patrol
frontman Gary Lightbody leads a battalion
of House Bolton soldiers in a rendition of
"The Bear and the Maiden Fair."
In the world of Westeros, this is a folk song
everybody seems to know. But in the real world,
it was necessary to make audiences aware that
the song exists, so that a later episode could
take that title and run with a very literal
interpretation of it.
Roy Dotrice
If you're a longtime fan of fantasy on television,
you probably remember Roy Dotrice as Ron Perlman's
wise father figure on Beauty and the Beast.
But if you're a fan of George R. R. Martin's
A Song of Ice and Fire, you probably know
him as the celebrated reader of the audiobooks.
He was personally chosen by Martin after the
two had worked together on Beauty and the
Beast and was originally announced as Grand
Maester Pycelle for the HBO series.
Due to health reasons, he was replaced by
Julian Glover. But fortunately, he was able
to appear in Season 2 as the pyromancer Hallyne.
While he isn't onscreen much, Hallyne plays
a key role in Tyrion's master plan for the
Battle of the Blackwater, so it's a fitting
use of an actor who will forever be linked
to the books.
David Benioff and D.B. Weiss
The House of Black and White, where Arya Stark
receives her training as a mystical assassin,
features an endless hall filled with columns
lined with the faces of the dead — not statues,
but the actual faces that have been removed
and serve as masks for the Faceless Men. Naturally,
the production design staff who made the faces
ended up including people they knew, most
notably show creators Benioff and Weiss, whose
faces occupy adjacent compartments that receive
a bit of camera time.
Mastodon
The American heavy metal band Mastodon didn't
perform music on Game of Thrones, but they
did contribute a song called "White Walker"
to the Catch the Throne Vol. 2 mixtape HBO
released to tie into the show in 2015. So
it wasn't surprising when members of the band
showed up in the episode "Hardhome," in which
they're killed and then resurrected by the
White Walkers. The band can thank Game of
Thrones executive producer D. B. Weiss for
those collaborative opportunities because
he's apparently a big fan of the group.
George W. Bush
In Game of Thrones' first season, Sansa is
made to look upon her father's severed head
by the cruel new King Joffrey. And while your
eyes may be scarred by the image of poor Lord
Stark, there are tons of other spiked heads
on display alongside him, including one resembling
former U.S. President George W. Bush, which
rests next to Sansa's septa.
Benioff and Weiss revealed that they used
the already-existing head prop for the scene
because of their need for heads, not for any
kind of political statement. But once the
word got out, some people found such a violent
depiction of a former president to be disrespectful.
This led to official apologies from HBO as
well as Benioff and Weiss.
Sigur Rós
Another memorable musical cameo comes at Joffrey
and Margaery's wedding in Season 4. The Icelandic
post-rock band Sigur Rós shows up with a
strange set of musical instruments to perform
a droning take on the House Lannister song
"The Rains of Castamere." It did not please
the king.
"Very good, very good, off you go."
Will Champion
In one of the most chilling episodes of the
entire series, Coldplay drummer Will Champion
joined the cast to bang the drums in the hall
of the Twins before all hell broke loose.
He's shown merrily thumping away as Edmure
Tully and his new bride are sent to their
wedding bed, blissfully unaware of the Red
Wedding massacre that's about to go down.
"That is a very strange custom."
Noah Syndergaard
Ed Sheeran wasn't the only familiar face to
make his debut in Season 7. New York Mets
pitcher Noah Syndergaard also made a buzzy
cameo in the new season as one of House Lannister's
foot soldiers who has incredible aim with
spear-throwing.
We don't know if his character survived the
ensuing dragon attack, but in light of how
the rest of the army fared, he probably didn't
last long in the skirmish. And considering
the Mets' 2017 season...he's probably used
to it.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!